objectivement j'aimerais d'abord faire
plaisir à mes fans c'est ces derniers
jours c'est à dire je pense que
j'animerai un thé pmp toute la journée
sur ces 8 mais ça veut dire que ce sera
votre mort et la mort de sept
c'était le dernier jour de votre vie
vous castaldi peut-être une opération
des yeux une ultime non j'ai feront un
devoir la mort arriver non je pense que
je ferais l'amour
l'érection avec tout vos ex femme non
pas du tout
avec votre femme avec aurore way ah oui
je vis avec qui sait pas non mais
attendez c'est le dernier jour on s'en
fout il le saura jamais mais que le
reste du temps
mais non sans rigoler c'est le dernier
jour derrière ces petits tu t'en fous
bref un fantasme oiseaux en baisse
continue comme outil nous avec qui
on s'en fout un peu au pire des cas tu
meurs sais pas si je suis bon après tout
le monde chez nous alors vas-y épisode
nous au nom non kelly peut-être
je
je la tue c'est quoi tes mentors
une action aura quoi qu'il arrive
non mais non mais attendez la sympathie
on
commence à dire vocation
d'accord d'accord oui c'est voilà ces
genres et si possible des jours
la croque daniel que vous aviez dirrell
chaque faux pas court bien
non mais sans déconner tu dis que vous
feriez alors
sans rigoler c'est vrai nom mais goûter
attendait fatigué
pour goûter à tous les plaisirs
quelqu'un d'autre autour de la table
daniel guillaume
[Applaudissements]
si tu lis pas
je suis là tu lui poser trois questions
la météo il reste un hétéro sur ces
13 mrd gilles la raison il faut pas
mourir il encore dit
magie ballon dit alors ah oui en maths
en deux minutes je pense que là tu as
fait un bel aveu du bas c'est très bien
cela quant à la guitare qui le démange
est-ce que tu regarde parfois aussi des
films avec des garçons je t'aime bien
des signes de la détresse que tu arrives
de bien ce garçon est très beau ouais
non mais j'ai pas pensé à vous mais j'ai
parfois pensé à guillon
et en quels termes tu peux développer un
petit peu les gens écoutent érotico
cérébrale que moi je suis cérébrale
c'est dur
non mais une scène dans sa voiture
pourquoi pas le dernier jour ils
s'aiment dans la voiture de guillaume
pourquoi pas mais ça
derrière si je suis mais c'est pas ça
ici c'est la foire aux gays pourquoi moi
je
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la bague
lui léguait benjamin il vient
c'est vrai que là ce côté c'est aux
côtés des questions l'avenir chacun ses
goûts poser des questions si vous êtes
bien sûr vous posez des questions s'il
faut y aller ou pas dans le camion
et cherchent chaussure à son pied
je suis se pose des questions elle se
dit oui mais quand
tu as autant que ça arrange
[Applaudissements]
d'année gaulois ont finalement
logique c'était doit choisir parce que
du coup pourquoi donc ça veut dire que
le dernier jour de rugby quoi qu'il
arrive vous les quêtes oui
je vais faire une patrouille dans
l'arène dernier truc l'orc soufflerie à
guillaume parce que guillaume il a
quelque chose de magnétique il a il a un
charme oui un intellectuel cérébrale et
là les très belles tenues que j'apprécie
j'aime beaucoup y est qu avec lui dans
la voiture voulait vraiment je vous dise
juste moi dans la voiture d'un bac pro 2
vitesse l'auteur bien une scène torride
à l'arrière de la voiture pourquoi pas
oui d'accord ou et chauffeurs qui nous
emmènerait au bout du monde alors chiche
pour ne pas être ce chauffeur
j'y vais assez d'horreur guillaume
ventura qui recettes cet aveu c'est un
grand nom
[Rires]
des frites ne plaît pas on sait juste
moi en fait j'ai si c'était mon dernier
jour je réaliserai un autre de mes
fantasmes
en fait je suis très inquiet c'est une
meuf gdm sur un stade qui ne répond pas
maintenant c'est vrai c'est daniel
moreau a dit mme année le moment mais si
avec des mdm c'est daniel way
en fait c'est parce que j'ai faim j'ai
failli écrire un mot sur
instagram
à l'essai en vue vous amassez
oui c'est quoi un dm tu vois un message
privé quoi voyez vous la ouais j'en ai
plein
[Applaudissements]
elle raconte certifié quoi certains chez
toi
alors et donc donc j'ai fait un rêve un
peu torride avec elle cette nuit donc
deux derniers jours de ta vie tu sais
que tu vas mourir c'est tu te donner le
mot reste ailleurs daniel roussée
l'inaccessible en fait irène manière ça
m'a un peu ici incapacité à elle m'a mis
en avant et donc j'ai fait un rêve un
peu torride avec elle c'est nous
proposer un plan semblable à dans les
loges
sama samaja moustier et que si ces
derniers jours je dirais oui non mais
c'est sur notre dernier jour avant les
noms mais si c'est son dernier jour ah
oui ah ben on est obligé quoi ah ouais
donc c'est bon ouais ça parce que c'est
le dernier jour seulement ils seront en
liquidation
jean surtout 3
si les trois là c'est le début d'un film
j'en
suis vraiment me dit qu'il est bien je
défais très bon attention est fermé
et très amer savez la porte et plus
controversés le
barbecue
merci je viens mon bouc volley coire
totalement différent moi je veux une
voiture de police pour traverser paris à
toute vitesse pour griller tous les feux
rouges je veux le solde est mon livret a
et faire des droits tout le monde
ensuite je vais y monte géraldine
et je bouscule de l'ordre
[Applaudissements]
alors je n'espère qu'une chose et qu'ils
mordent
vraiment à ouidah mais je suis là
parce que pour un club mais ce que j'ai
on va pas mourir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non
mais d'abord il assez
de dire la vérité à tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
sur
son dernier jeu il arrive en dernier que
l'attrait du déo
de la
force quand même au début mais voilà ça
alors qu'est ce que vous feriez vous
kebbi abat d'abord j'assouvis tous les
besoins de tout le monde
[Rires]
il
est ouvert déjà ça vous fait
huawei rien d'exceptionnel je vais quand
même chez zara
j'insulte énormément de gens j'avais
parfois je mange je fais l'amour avec
mon mec je vais voir ma famille puis
après je pense que c'est bon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est
ce que
j'ai envie de savoir après parce que
j'ai l'impression que parce qu'il va y
avoir beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui
vont se passer une feuille à quoi je
prends un avion et je vais dans sur une
île déserte avec mon amoureux et vous
allez maintenant il ya au total c'est
quoi cette race rare est sauvé c'est
l'un des jours à l'échéance
août 2010
[Applaudissements]
on y goûte quelques chants et ses
contrôles
désert et schleck
hier le dernier jour
dans l'avion faire des passes
les jours demain
mais sans révélations truc on y voit un
truc mais c'est pas fait l'amour en
public valérie mais je sais pas moi tu
te lâches il doit là j'ai pas bien
triste pour toi
mais j'accepte tout
juste me passer dessus c'est dérangeant
t'as rien à voir a aucun lien de
filiation mail avec gilles lui c'est mon
frère ça sort d'où sayyaf à ce père de
famille
du sang et les banques pourraient pas ça
pour elle et passe même même au zizi
dirais non mais je vous dis il faut lui
parler non mais je veux dire c'est
vraiment très fort vous feriez quoi vous
alors moi je m'adresserai aux plus
généreux d'entre nous celui qui dit
toujours oui pour les causes désespérées
vous avez tous deviné tirs
[Applaudissements]
faire des maisons temporaires des voix
tu attends avoir du bonheur aux gens
et les jaunes c'est trottinette tous les
soirs des iphones au public dès 5 heures
il répond aux galères la vérité ma
top-10 raynaud
j'adore daniel et ça qu'elle me plaît
énormément
mais
mais malheureusement même si c'est votre
dernier jour vous savez que je suis très
très à cheval sur les gestes barrières
[Rires]
c'est vraiment dur mais le sexe dans la
main
tout est là
faute et je vais vous dire je vais vous
dire daniel joret mais de dire oui
malheureusement la direction de ses
beats refuse
et
je veux te dire la raison pour laquelle
il ne veut pas que ça forniquent entre
personnes de même émission
[Applaudissements]
tous virés
[Rires]
qu'est ce que tu voudrais faire ce
dernier jour c'est à dire oui quand même
pas alors après j'avais je pensé que
vous seriez prêt
pour faire soit
vous amoureux
privé de son corps
avant de partir
[Applaudissements]
x
exactement un petit coin
j'ai pas séduit c'est un doigt
[Rires]
des nues
vous voyez bien ce qui va évidemment
elle a conquis
les chiens alors je dois vous êtes con
cette affaire sur la bella c'est ça mon
âge
un doigt vous êtes d'accord c'est un
domestique
et leurs amis l'appellent l'abus
d'alcool est dangereux pour la santé
regardez ce que ça donne
je pose des questions mais vous êtes
devenu complètement fou il perd sur
17 concerne toulouse
parce que là je ne sens pas bien
imaginer imaginons scénario sabrina elle
est à l'article de la mort la seule
personne qui peut la sauver c'est vous
en lui faisant l'amour oui mais pas
cette année moi ça ne me dérange pas là
fait saillie
ça va être vraiment sauver des gens
quand on tape à votre porte et qu'on te
dit c'est le moment faut
il faut savoir quitter la table quand le
vieil aréna servi non mais et je te le
dis franchement
c'est ça ou mourait
à c'est moi qui vous sont assez bons
alors c'est quoi alors c'est un autre je
sais mais c'est moi qui vous
le dit fort par un baiser par voyez
comme dans l'est dans les contes de fées
quoi
[Musique]
tomber le doigt dans l'engrenage
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors tu as mal alors oui qu'est ce que
vous voulez c'est au début moi on veut
pas tuer après défoncer
pour vous ouais je vous dis et que ce
qu'on est amis depuis de nombreuses
années je pense qu'il vaut mieux que je
meurs et que je ne saute pas
ça risque et je le dis ça risque de
flinguer notre amitié mais
l'ouvrir à perdre cette amitié
[Musique]
il prend les dernières heures qu'elle a
dit j'ai envie qu'on soit quand même
encore à me caler ses souvenirs dans la
tête quand elle sera là haut
tu
avais fait un jeu je donne tout ce que
j'ai
[Applaudissements]
du coup
je prends je prends un papier ces jeunes
offre exactement le montant gauche et
ouais voilà en qualité jeauneau divise
krumm
ans
je devrais parts égales à tous alors est
ce lorientais veut bouffer les coups de
botte
vous rendez compte que
vous avez mardi l'insee quoi qu'on
faisait mauvaise mine
[Rires]
de l'amour avec personne ouais ouais
alors vous n'êtes pas là dedans vous
être que dans le nom mais j'ai toujours
pensé non générosité je n'ai rien donné
les mannequins
géorgien non franchement je préfère
vraiment janvier voilà heureux et vous
pensiez à moi est beau et bon voilà il
faut vous profitiez ça vous fait pas
plaisir
qu'on n'y croit pas vraiment c'est bon
mais c'est faux c'est faux ça sent pas
vraiment le truc
bien ces montagnes basques os et moi de
l'argent plus un petit bdc je suis
heureux
du bus
en plein mouvement